hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday May 2nd 2016 and I know I always
make that joke like oh my god we're in
the year going but seriously guys
seriously where the [ __ ] is this year
going what the [ __ ] May 2nd already May
[ __ ] second we're getting ready for
the stop into Meg I'm psyched I'm
psyched that we're into May
because Maine means were closer to the
middle of July and in the middle of the
Jill of July I will be done writing you
know helping to write the second season
of efforts for family and then I'm free
not really but sort of and I'll have two
weeks off and the old freckles rumor has
it is going to be doing a doing a nice
run through Europe so which might may or
may not start in Ireland it's all sort
of loose at this point but we're
slugging it out and I'm actually feeling
much better by the way thank you for not
asking with my sciatica sciatica sounds
like a [ __ ] speed metal band you know
not a good one not right come see my
band sciatica
we're going to be down at the ground
route on Wednesday night okay yeah I'll
definitely see it bye so like you think
maybe you could like bring some people
you know I'm gonna do what I can
all right so is that like I definitely
put you down do [ __ ] off if I get there
I'll get there i brung chill sciatica
sorry I actually I got some I found some
new stretches I found this [ __ ] guy
on on YouTube this doctor who is just
sitting on a yoga mat one of these
[ __ ] new-age you guys you know what I
mean well those guys that's like
straight but it still makes you
uncomfortable you know those you know
those straight guys like you're straight
up gay guy is not uncomfortable to be
around but there's a certain kind of
straight guy that's coming off like he's
gay but he's straight that is the most
uncomfortable male to be around I don't
why you don't I mean it's almost like
they got something between their teeth
and you just can't even hear what the
[ __ ] they're saying you want to be like
can you just go and get the [ __ ] out of
here so I can listen to you is there a
word for that the gay-straight guy yeah
bill it's called a gay guy getting
caught in the closet well maybe it isn't
some some guys are just some guys are
just effeminate some guys just stand
there and gym class is one person after
another is called to be on the team is a
stereotype right just gay athletes it
was that guy who played on the big 12
there in Missouri and then he went to
that football team and then he got cut
much been hard to cut him right all
right how bad does this guy have to suck
before we won't get accused of being
homophobic when we caught him you know
that's always in the air but that's not
what I wanted to talk about I'm here to
talk about science what's their sex robe
turns out my hamstring was [ __ ] up so
I was doing like the touch of toe
stretchers which is the exact opposite
thing that you want to do because the
nerve is like pinched or inflamed and
you're just like your your you're not
stretching it or what I guess you
stretch the muscles really so whatever
and usually a stretches around the nerve
I have no idea I never even heard of
this [ __ ] thing until I had this
problem and God knows I didn't take any
Anatomy classes so I think when you
don't have a nerve issue you can then do
that Bend because well what you're
stretching really is just your muscle
your muscle fibers muscle tissue and the
nerves are just sort of chilling around
it but when it gets pinched between the
[ __ ] anterior cruciate ligament of
the lower [ __ ] vertebrae tailbone
whatever the [ __ ] it is all you know is
like [ __ ] [ __ ] pulling a balloon
uninflated balloon I have no [ __ ]
analogy I don't know what all I know is
it hurt so I put this guy on this hippie
guy and he was just like yeah man what
you actually want to do is you don't
this there's certain stretches that you
wanted you and you're serious and
stretch it you don't want to do and
you know we're in an age right now I'm
so [ __ ] impatient I was trying to
skip ahead by just had to sit there you
know everything I could do just to get
to a nine minute video it's only nine
minutes out of my day but there's like a
flat-screen TV with NBA and NHL playoffs
going on I got other videos I can click
on you know I'm sitting there trying to
listen to this guy I'm also looking at
all the videos on the right you know
there's free porn there's all kinds of
[ __ ] and this guy is just sitting there
going you know okay good good stretch
that you want to do is is actually if
you just sit down on your buttocks make
sure your weight is on your your pelvic
bones and I was just it was driving me
[ __ ] insane but what I ended up doing
the stretch of the night and I
definitely feel better so thanks to that
guy whatever his [ __ ] name is and I
will definitely be posting those in case
anybody else has that problem if you're
just sitting down in a chair and like
your feet go numb and [ __ ] you could
possibly have what I have or you got a
big dog sitting in your lap one of the
other I have no [ __ ] idea but I'm
just happy that it uh that it feels
better and I got to tell you all these
[ __ ] aches and pains that I'm having
I knew this a long time ago there's
nothing better than stretching now that
I've gone out and I bought all this
[ __ ] rogue Fitness [ __ ] you know to
lift weights and all the atomic grips
and all that [ __ ] to do the Ninja
Warrior stuff like the best thing I
could be doing all that [ __ ] is that
shit's all going to be great provided I
[ __ ] stretch but um I don't know I
wish I knew way way way way [ __ ] back
in the day to stretch there was no
stretching in the 80s [ __ ] with the
Gold's Gym you just did the old you know
you did the stretch you did before you
started lifting at Gold's Gym back in
the 80s you remember [ __ ] Chevy Chase
when he's about ready to jump in the
pool Christie Brinkley where he's going
this is crazy this is crazy she's crazy
you know he's moving his [ __ ] eye
that's what you did he did a couple of
those and then he did like you stuck
your arm to the side
you did those [ __ ] you know touch
your left hand to your right toe and up
and down you know one two [ __ ] those
military things one two three
Paul I love Marine Corps you doing that
[ __ ] right without stretching and then
you would just [ __ ] work out
I [ __ ] out myself so much [ __ ] up my
tricep I tore a PEC you know you know
it's funny all of this shit's going to
come back to haunt me the next time I
lose my [ __ ] health insurance if
somewhere just listen to this podcast
and list everything that I'm talking
about is some sort of pre-existing
condition now you probably all built
you're doing well how do you keep losing
your health insurance well because you
do an acting gig they pay you one time
and then they start sending your
residual checks for like a dollar thirty
five and you have to make 10 grand a
year minimal to keep your every single
year you got to make it you got to make
that or something like that to keep your
[ __ ] sag after [ __ ] health
insurance and you know one year goes by
and you're writing a show rather than
being on the show you [ __ ] lose your
you end up loose I mean I do anyways I
haven't done enough you know I'm done
enough acting work I guess you know you
think with 58 fast and furious 47 Friday
the 13th you think I could catch on
enough to make 10 grand a year you know
what I blame in the [ __ ] after stag
health health insurance I think I got to
take this one I got to take this one
myself I gotta look myself in the
[ __ ] mirror and be like you know what
Bill it's your goddamn fault your own
[ __ ] fault don't you just go out and
get Blue Cross Blue Shield that's what I
should do I should just walk away from
sag after right I don't [ __ ] know I'm
a big advocate of that you know looking
yourself in the mirror and being like
alright you [ __ ] up as opposed to
being like you know the world is unfair
which everybody knows it is right but if
you say alright I [ __ ] up that it
actually gives you an option to be okay
what can I do to lessen the [ __ ] up
because I know I'm going to [ __ ] up
again you know
like if you're like Caitlyn Jenner right
now rather than [ __ ] filming yourself
taking a piston Trump Tower you know why
don't you just look yourself in there
and be like all right how did I
[ __ ] this up you know for the first
sixty-six years of my life I had a
definitive bathroom to go into there
wasn't any question nor did I have to
film myself and then afterwards say I
didn't molest anybody what has happened
to that person you know that that person
has absolutely lost their [ __ ] mind
who's walking around filming themselves
taking a piss and then talking about
child molesters and I know what people
would say oh you can't have these
[ __ ] former guys with boobs now they
have you know you know they're
transitioning people you can get a
[ __ ] molest somebody bla bla bla bla
I know that that's what that whole
[ __ ] thing was supposed to be about
but you know that just came off to me
shameless self-promotion I don't have
anything against transgendered people
but that's [ __ ] dingbat it's funny I
think that is the proper word because
you know she identifies with the female
sex so I think dingbat now works as
opposed to douche bag see I kept the D I
went I went alliteration ice kid never
fully you know what I would never call
Bruce a douche bag because he was on the
Wheaties box you know I don't know about
this cable know that so the jury's still
out Oh Bruce did kill somebody you know
accidentally Caitlyn has yet to
accidentally kill somebody so I you know
there's a lot of math to be done you
know what I strike all that I think I
think she was right to film herself
peeing in a skyscraper you know whenever
I see a video like that I always wonder
if people who are truly suffering around
the world if they ever get access to a
laptop and just somehow that comes up on
their [ __ ] YouTube page you know what
I mean they're just living like in like
those people that like Brazil that live
in those [ __ ] trash heaps if somehow
they see [ __ ] Caitlyn Jenner's
walking around acting like a victim you
know wearing shoes that they probably
[ __ ] sewed together at 3 o'clock in
the [ __ ] morning
oh I know I know you're supposed to care
about everything I don't I don't give a
[ __ ] you don't to give a [ __ ] about
right now cyanic coming to the
Providence always the Wooster Providence
Civic Center Wooster Civic Senate No ah
[ __ ] I can t remember that's all I give
a [ __ ] about I give a [ __ ] about now
being able to [ __ ] reach down and pick
up a dirty sock without having a [ __ ]
bolt of lightning go down the back of my
leg that would be nice right
maybe I'm transitioning I'm
transitioning into a [ __ ] old man
right before my very eyes you know my
[ __ ] dog had just been sweets all
damn day
I know I always bring this [ __ ] up but
it just blows me away
I've watched you around the block fit
it's all there was man anyway so I've
been watching not as much as I can my
wife's been on the road
so I immediately become a bachelor
however I've kept this place pretty
clean you know and that's a very
important thing to do when you're
married is when your spouse leaves you
have to [ __ ] and show them that you can
live without them I think that's a huge
[ __ ] thing like she so wants to come
home and just see this [ __ ] place and
absolute like see that you couldn't live
without me you know what I mean which I
could not I would be [ __ ] devastated
if she [ __ ] left or anything
obviously I would be but you know what I
mean you do have to have a little bit of
self esteem so I've gone back to the way
I used to live like I have one plate one
fork that's all I music and I just put
it in the sink and if I need another one
I just wash that one it's great it's
nice and quick saves a lot of water
right Ed Begley Jr would be so [ __ ]
happy with me right now
one plate one fork I'm really into that
type of [ __ ] and that's very hard to be
into that type of [ __ ] when when you
have a woman in your life you know not
having a lot of stuff because [ __ ] be
like and
I don't know what it is they can't get
enough of [ __ ] Amazon
I wonder what percentage of people you
know this some [ __ ] guy but that
doctor did a feminine straight doctor
that helped me with sciatica
I bet he's on Amazon all the time you
know trying to find a new pair of
[ __ ] puffy pants the mattress sandals
been amazing that this guy helped me out
the way he did and I'm still [ __ ]
damage to the human as a human being
that I still have to make fun of them
and when you know what you want for me
so anyways the update with the gym
all right I'll actually show you guys
before and after pictures when when I'm
done because it's just a [ __ ] garage
I don't give a [ __ ] if you see that so I
got the pegboard up I actually what I
had before was you know those you know
those really long peg boards where your
arms are really close together and
they're like they go on for [ __ ] ever
you know my garage you know it has like
a [ __ ] 8 foot ceiling so that wasn't
an option so I bought two of those and
mounted them sideways to ice just just
do the pegboard exercise sideways you
don't try go all the way down and come
all the way back and now where they
moved them they actually cut them in
half and put all four side by side so
the goal is eventually to go up one down
the other up the third and down the
fourth I got that up I got the speed bag
up that's more for my wife she's into
that [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about that
you know that's always that was a big
thing when I was growing up having a
heavy bag and all that [ __ ] you know and
then people thought they were tougher
because they were hitting a heavy bag
that has no [ __ ] arms or legs you
know you basically just you you beaten
up again you're basically practicing to
fight a [ __ ] is all you were really
doing I mean granted there was cardio
involved but actually I remember a long
time ago seeing a [ __ ] guy with no
arms and no legs as a wrestler and
nobody could beat him they just there
was nothing to hook and again he would
just do I don't know what he was doing
but he would somehow flip these people's
like can you just imagine wrestling just
a rock
you know but it was a long flat one and
somehow it [ __ ] could move and it had
a head on it I don't know how to
describe this [ __ ] kid all I know is
he was winning so maybe maybe there is
something about that you know what can i
backtrack I don't think I've had one at
one point that I've made in this entire
podcast that I haven't I haven't
retracted from well you know what it's a
[ __ ] election year what's the guy's B
which was the other guy running other
than Donald Trump Hillary Clinton
kidding Ted Cruz Ted Cruz I don't know
anything about Ted Cruz but evidently
he's really interested about where
caitlyn jenner drops a [ __ ] deuce and
Caitlyn made a [ __ ] oh snapchat [ __ ]
video right is that what happened that
what happened on [ __ ] Facebook this
week I'm still out of the loop everybody
so out of the loop just can you guys
just ride with me for the next couple of
[ __ ] months as i spend my entire
waking hours in a [ __ ] writers room i
don't [ __ ] see anything i don't read
anything we just stare at a computer
screen i'm going to need [ __ ] glasses
by the time i'm done with this [ __ ] my
act is drying up thank you no I'm
finished [ __ ] on Caitlyn Jenner
thank God she [ __ ] made that video
because I ended up getting a great bit
out of it this weekend I [ __ ] it up
the first time and then the next time it
it worked so that's always great you
know you got a love topical material
topical material is like the delitos of
[ __ ] stand-up you know what I mean
it's [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] satisfying
but there's just no nutrition in it
whatsoever but anyways like I was saying
before I went down to the the Comedy
Store in 3d Kenny I can't [ __ ]
believe it it looks like a goddamn
nightclub there's all these young people
in there is beautiful women all dressed
up and [ __ ] just having a great time
like it's like I don't know I wasn't
around during the 80s but I don't know I
don't know how it could have been any
better just as far as the sheer amount
of people coming out in them and their
lappers too so if you are in the LA area
it's a good time to go down there and I
was on you know the shows I was on was
just [ __ ] one monster [ __ ] comic
after another that's probably another
reason like one of my favorites I
consider my new guys Chris D'Elia who
goes down there what I love about that
guy is just as a stand-up comic I love
seeing a legitimate headliner you know
there's a lot of people that can sell
tickets because they're on TV or they
did a movie thing or they took a piss
and Donald Trump's [ __ ] tower right
Caitlyn Jenner would sell out of [ __ ]
improv but there's very few people that
could basically follow anybody go out
there and really level like the point at
which that you have to level to really
be considered a [ __ ] headliner and
this guy [ __ ] does it so yeah there
was a bunch of people who the [ __ ] was
on the show I went on at the Dane Cook
he [ __ ] murdered I got there late on
that one and then the next show I was
working with Chris D'Elia and Natasha
Leggero was on Bobby Lee by the way
speaking of Natasha at anybody see the
new Dice Clay [ __ ] series I love it
did you see a jerk or two out my guy my
[ __ ] up his name is it Adrian Brody why
don't I know anybody's name he did this
whole [ __ ] thing where he was playing
himself and he was you know and his next
acting role was to play Dice Clay Andrew
Dice Clay in a biopic so the whole
episode he's trying to get dice I don't
want to ruin it just [ __ ] watch it
his Dice Clay is is [ __ ] tremendous
and I don't know speaking of the
Worcester Centrum I've always been a
huge Dice Clay fan and I saw him I know
I've told this story before but that's
where I saw him in like 1988 I saw him
at the Worcester Centrum with an unknown
Eddie Griffin opening up and it was
Chuck he [ __ ] murdered
he did a drum solo at the end of the end
it was one of the sickest shows I ever
saw and I still didn't realize that I
wanted to be a comedian
how [ __ ] dumb I was when I was
growing up you know I used to memorize
comedy albums and I would ride around my
bicycle you know doing my paper route
reciting those aunt those albums
pretending I was doing them in the in
the school auditorium in front of the
entire school and it still never dawned
on me like hey bill that probably means
that you want to be a comedian like I
never had never [ __ ] done it seemed
like it was a million miles away you
know we didn't have YouTube you know
could just film yourself taking a [ __ ]
at a Dairy Queen and say take that
presidential candidate if you couldn't
[ __ ] do that back then
anyways so as always I'm going to talk
about another car that I like him and I
probably will never buy I was watching
something on that Tesla s and it's like
the self-driving [ __ ] car and these
two guy computer looking guys I'll say
that because they both had glasses so if
you have glasses in my world that means
you're smart and a lot of people's world
it means that you know but you know I
want to be politically correct maybe
they were both a couple of [ __ ] heads
but anyways they were in this car and
they put on the self-driving mode and
according to the video they put blankets
over themselves and they took a [ __ ]
nap now Tesla said that there's some
alarming YouTube videos of people doing
[ __ ] in their cars that you're not
supposed to be doing but they basically
took a nap and then somebody wrote in
one of the comments underneath it like
would you get arrested if you got
shit-faced put it on self-driving mode
and then sat in the backseat and you
don't make you don't know me maybe you
think you know me but I'm always
bitching about technology I actually am
coming around to the self-driving car
just provided that you could still drive
it if you want to because that is that
is pretty [ __ ] cool do you realize
well [ __ ] out of shape and like you
know how bad like
this is going to be for procrastinators
you know the fact that they no longer
have to drive themselves to work and
they're going to be trying to finish the
[ __ ] presentation in their car you
know you've seen people brushing their
teeth of just people literally with an
eye mask on just [ __ ] sleeping in the
Jam jams and then they pull up to work
you know like you set your car alarm and
that's like your [ __ ] alarm to wake
you up like when it stops and it's in
park you know maybe the horn just goes
bad and that
that'd be too jarring that beacon
jarring for people of the future right
they don't want to [ __ ] deal with
anything they just want to lay around
right so they [ __ ] let you lay there
in the car and you know those [ __ ]
creepy cells vibrating [ __ ] seats
when you get too close to something
maybe it does that you just lay in there
right it just sort of shakes you a
little bit some weird creepy computer
voice you can pick the voice to write
you know God knows celebrities will jump
all over that they do the [ __ ]
voiceovers to make a little bit of cash
because no one pays for movies anymore
and they're just sick of being and those
mighty heroes [ __ ] superhero movies
one after another they're literally out
of ideas huh I mean once you have like
the superheroes fighting each other they
got to be nervous in Hollywood just
going like where do we go from here you
know can we reboot this thing again can
we reboot the [ __ ] Joker and all that
you know what the funny thing is though
is people will keep showing up I guess
that makes sense right
God knows they've had the comic books
forever and people keep reading those
you know what I'm not taking that one
back I'm wrong about that one again have
I been right yeah [ __ ] bunch of swings
and misses so anyways that Tesla s has
another feature where you can like call
the car like a [ __ ] dog like if it's
in a tight parking spot you can just go
here
and for 10% one can have fun huh you
want to go for a drive right and the
thing just slowly backs up it comes to
you it's literally it's like the [ __ ]
Knight Rider car and like I said I am
usually anti-technology and but every
once in a while something comes along
and I even me as much as I like in
freckled content I am I have to sit back
and be like you know what that's cool so
here's the thing the car cost like I
don't know like a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars so I imagine ninety
percent of the people you know not
trying to talk down to you okay will say
80% of that listen to this [ __ ] thing
right just went like outrageous I'll
never be able to for that yeah you will
I'll tell you what okay I'll give you
I'll give you [ __ ] three examples
calculators rollerblades and flat-screen
TVs all of those things when they came
out they were [ __ ] ridiculously
expensive and then by the end of it they
gave them away with like a free tank of
[ __ ] gas well maybe not the [ __ ]
flatscreen so you remember like we'll go
back to calculate errs first came out
they were a hundred dollars each
something crazy like that and then they
did they just kept dropping dropping
dropping dropping dropping as more and
more people bottom and then they had the
solar ones in the next thing you know
you got a calculator with the [ __ ]
free fill up at the gas station
rollerblades were always over a hundred
bucks right and everybody had them and
then like what the [ __ ] we're going to
do with the rest of them and next thing
you know there was 30 bucks all right
flat-screen TVs when they first came out
I for some reason remember them to be
about 11 grand when they first came out
you know and they were about as thick as
my [ __ ] head let me look this up here
original price original price of
flat-screen TVs I'm saying 11 grand
flat screen black screen falling cost of
flat screens or the farm Jesus Christ
I'll never find it
Oh the price was 14090 almost 15 grand
999 dollars for
plasma TV plasma display TV yada yada
yada Vantage's disadvantages where the
[ __ ] was it history
- logo - mm mm the 40 inch TV cost you
know what go [ __ ] yourself I don't know
what the [ __ ] was it actually came up
and then I clicked on it then the
information disappears sorry about that
I'm just saying so I bet that Tesla that
technology well well you know it's like
when airbags first came out they run
Mercedes they protected the rich people
first and then once they got all the
rich people's money then they got all
right you know what
maybe we'll protect the middle class and
then eventually it gets all the way down
to like you know like there's starving
kids in Africa that probably have
rollerblades you know what I mean and
like a Chicago Blackhawks 2016 advance
to the second round t-shirt right you
know they always get those [ __ ] and
to get those hats like Boston Red Sox
1986 World Series champions who's always
so many diggin for a Blood Diamond we're
in that [ __ ] Buffalo Bills four in a row
you know that's like what a sex slave
t-shirt you know sexual aid wears over
and [ __ ] down on one of those sex
slave countries are you making light of
this thank you Mike that's trade no I'm
just talking I'm making fun of the
Buffalo Bills there I feel for the
person that it was sold into sex slavery
but I don't feel bad for the Buffalo
Bills you know what I mean you know why
they lost all four of those because nice
guys finish last and Marv levy is
everything that Pete Carroll looks like
he is Pete Carroll is is Marv levy 2.0
both of them just look like you could
just trust them
you know I could leave I could leave a
stack of [ __ ] cash here right in
front of my life savings I will come
back and I'm going to be fine and and
that is true with Marv levy and that's
why he lost four Super Bowls now if you
were to leave that with Pete Carroll you
know I'm you know I don't think I have
to tell you yet you know the
foolish chicks over there and he had
wing sauce on his face and be like I
stole their funky talking about why my
[ __ ] not Pete Carroll I know you think
of don't load about your coach what
about [ __ ] now or Bob Bill Belichick
well he doesn't look hopeful he looks
like a mean dad doesn't he's like a good
dad's home God such a douche you know
that's that's really looking like Pete
Carroll looks like you know Pete Carroll
looks like he goes to church you know
and on the third day Jesus will rise
again and then he's in the back and go
well that paid he always gets excited
during that part of the Jesus story Oh
Jay Jay's oh what the [ __ ] was with that
guy you know I actually tweeted about
that guy in the draft that got busted
you know we're in the [ __ ] gas masks
taking the [ __ ] weed hit and
everybody gave me [ __ ] cause you didn't
watch the trap it's like dude it kind of
became it went viral actually I was
actually texted to me by a another
comedian was letting me know he said in
real time this guy was getting
blackmailed and I ended up watching the
clips dude that was that guy should fire
his [ __ ] agent yesterday that poor
bastard
nobody he had no advice he was sitting
there sweating if nobody came out that
woman didn't say hey hey that's enough
no more questions if she didn't rescue
him that guy would still be sitting
there like pouring sweat answering every
[ __ ] question that they asked what's
most fucked-up thing you ever jerked off
to well I would have to say you know
it's just like I don't know where his
agent was but um he was somewhere
high-fiving himself I think goddamnit
that Tesla is a good-looking car from
the side I just hate the front end it's
just weird you know because it doesn't
need a [ __ ] doesn't need a grill
because it doesn't have a radiator
because it doesn't have an engine to
[ __ ]
you know cool off or whatever I was
going to say Oh it'd be cool to just put
it in there anyways but then air would
get trapped in it was actually slowed
down dude that's the [ __ ] car that's
the car you want that thing is fast it's
actually beats a [ __ ] Lamborghini it
beats a Ferrari zero to sixty it [ __ ]
smokes that car literally smokes a
[ __ ] supercar now when they get up to
the higher there's this you know [ __ ]
seventy eighty miles an hour
the Ferrari overtakes it who gives a
[ __ ] give the [ __ ] eighty ninety miles
an hour I mean I guess the only reason
to want a car going that fast if you
take it to the track if you [ __ ]
drive 100 miles an hour a regular street
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're
going to kill somebody
so you know what god damn it I think I'm
going to get that car oh Jesus that's a
good-looking car get it black huh with
the red [ __ ] caliber now I'm too
[ __ ] I'm too frugal can't blow 120
down what's a [ __ ] car payment on
that so [ __ ] morgue you could buy a
third Detroit for the amount of money
you're going to pay for a [ __ ] Tesla
that's insane you know I watched the
trashiest [ __ ] YouTube videos and I
really have to stop doing it because
everything like for some reason I was
looking at the top ten inappropriate
police officer pictures posted online
and then once you do that then you just
stuck in this thing top ten things
banned in the United States
inappropriate family photos that will
make you cringe you know most of them
are staged but you still sit there and
watch at the top ten [ __ ] creepy
things ever dug up the top ten weird
things in the background of some [ __ ]
took a picture of her [ __ ] ass and a
song ten most dangerous gangs in the
world alright I'll look at this guy's
all [ __ ] tattooed up holding the baby
ten of the most dangerous gangs in the
world this is what I do with my wife's
out of town
i watch playoff hockey and then I had
that on and then I [ __ ] sit here and
I look at this [ __ ]
15 most poisonous animals in the world
you know what it is I've seen every
failed video at this point I've seen
every people or awesome video I've seen
every fight video I've seen every
Instant Karma bully thing I just I just
feel like I've seen everything that I
give a [ __ ] about Instant Karma
fails five most dangerous people in the
world can act in acts 10 actors who
actually did it on-screen
I didn't see that wait a minute what the
[ __ ] is this one see and now I'm not
going to watch the most dangerous gangs
you look funny
as much most you'll make in front of me
right now and the other the rest of you
are googling this [ __ ] right now
the only way I feel I got any questions
my [ __ ] Andrew sent me the [ __ ]
question just because I don't have any
advertising ain't got nothing I'm trying
to get this [ __ ] out of the [ __ ] way
because I got to do a radio tour next
week to hike all my dates coming up in
Florida bill you come into Florida you
didn't mention that oh yeah going to all
the big cities - I'm going to Orlando
right home at Disneyworld now like that
small [ __ ] out here right just gives me
land this is Disneyworld May 6th I'm
going to be at the Seminole Hard Rock
Hotel and Casino in Hollywood Florida
then I'm going to be at the Hard Rock
Live in Orlando Florida doing two shows
and then on May 8th I'll be at the Times
Union Center for the Performing Arts
more in Moran Motul theater in
Jacksonville Florida and hopefully I'll
get there [ __ ] early enough I can go
to a gun range and shoot some [ __ ]
guns with silencers not some fun [ __ ]
[Music]
goddammit that's a good time
Jacksonville is underrated under [ __ ]
rated City to go to I know a lot of
people [ __ ] on
you know northern Florida but I got to
be honest with you I love a [ __ ] town
you know there's fun to be had anybody
can go to [ __ ] Miami go to some
[ __ ] Botox party whatever the [ __ ] it
is those people do down there it's like
you're not pretty enough you got to
[ __ ] laminate your face you know it's
just weird I like being the most you
know Tampa Clearwater Tallahassee
orlando jacksonville orlando is not even
bad Orlando's like for like Orange
County it just sort of you know it has
that McMansion vibe you know
I don't know a lot of people live out
that way because there's no law state
income tax that's why so many Burt
Reynolds ended up going out there Oh Jay
Simpson you know all the people that had
rough course cases you know double
murders divorces all of that [ __ ] you
know they all end up in Florida that's
when you know you know you know as you
get [ __ ] older I think you just
that's one of the major signs that you
were basically very successful but
married the wrong person slash maybe
killed somebody
as you end up in Florida if you're not
like indigenous to that area Rubel
indigenous somebody learned a [ __ ]
word huh all right let's see if I can
read some advertising here for the
goddamn week the goddamn week of May 2nd
you know I always make like a mental
note to myself at the beginning of May
even though I live out here in LA and
the [ __ ] weather is always great I
took like I always just remember like I
always be working and I'd be psyched it
was May and then before I realized that
it was into August I was thinking like
wow the first like 90 days of this [ __ ]
at least May in June I think people a
lot of people take May and June June for
[ __ ] granted I mean I don't know who
I'm even speaking to at this point does
anybody really even have four seasons
anymore but if you still live in an area
like this is the time where you gotta be
that guy to make the most of the decent
weather all right ok enough with that
[ __ ] let me read some of the
some of the advertising here for this
week all right sherry fairies Mother's
Day is this weekend only xx days away so
I guess I'm supposed to fill that in
well I'm reading this on May 1st so it's
7 days away it's um it's May 8th this
year there is no one quite like your mom
every mom is unique and we wouldn't want
to change a thing
talk about your mom or your wife's
quirks funny stories or sayings oh yeah
let's see I never tell my mother when
I'm on TV because she's a mom and no
matter what I do she's going to give me
[ __ ] you know I don't understand why you
wore that shirt I liked your performance
on Conan better than on The Tonight Show
now I love my mom but you know what I
mean she is like she she's my original
like Twitter troll my entire life I mean
one of the reasons why I'm so driven is
to just one day have a show or a [ __ ]
whatever whatever the [ __ ] you call
doing the talk show a segment on a talk
show where wire-to-wire she actually
goes like you know what I sat down and I
watched it and I don't have a problem
with anything you did you know I don't
know anyways that's my mom Oh going to
send some [ __ ] Justin strawberries
their way and with Mother's Day just
around the corner I have a great way to
show Mom how much you appreciate her
surprise mom with something unexpected
and it's unique as she is with Sherri's
berries right now she Aries berries
freshly dipped strawberry starting at
$19.99 plus shipping or double the
berries for just $10 more this is an
exclusive offer to my listeners or for
people with like stepmothers you know
you double the berries and then you
split the load go to berries calm click
on the microphone in the top right hand
corner and type in my code bur berries
dipped in milk white and dark chocolatey
goodness top with rich chocolate chips
chopped nuts and signature swizzle huge
fresh juicy delicious you pick the
delivery date you want and it's
guaranteed customers
affection is always guaranteed or your
money back it's a win-win just click on
the microphone in the top right hand
corner and type in Burpee you are our
go-to berries comm BER RI es click on
the microphone and enter my codename
Burke this is a limited time offer and
Mother's Day is this weekend so make
sure you order now it's a great thing to
do you know it's your mom don't just
give her a phone call give it a
chocolate strawberries you know what how
about you also give her a little little
bouquet of flowers down with ProFlowers
every time we ProFlowers is also where
that Mother's Day is this weekend only
[ __ ] 8 days 7 days away 6 days when
you hear this mom has always been an
expert on everything cooking
relationship advice stand-up comedy
fixing your cuts and bruises the one
thing you can't go to her for for advice
on is what to get her for Mother's Day
not to worry you're going to look like
an expert this Mother's Day when you use
profilers ProFlowers get mom 100 blooms
with a free glass vase for $19.99 plus
shipping and handling or make her day
extra-special and upgrade to a premium
base and add a gourmet chocolate and
there at gourmet chocolate for just
$9.99 more oh shot fired ProFlowers is
coming at Sherry's berries go to
proflowers.com today and use my code bar
Pro flowers are guaranteed to be fresh
and beautiful for at least 7 days your
money back you choose a delivery date
you want and it's guaranteed it's a
no-brainer here is the only way to get
100 blooms with a free glass vase
starting in 1999 visit proflowers.com
click the blue microphone in the top
right corner and type in birth that's
proflowers.com click on the microphone
on top
type in birth mother's Day is this
weekend so order now time is running out
this offer expires Friday at midnight
right well we got three more so let's
get three out of the way and we'll have
two left all right me on all but Oh boom
beyond each me undies no more sweaty
balls boo doo doo me undies me on D
stick them in a bathroom stall this
Sunday is Mother's Day get our pair of
pair
what do you say it's not too creepy
unless you think about it why did I sing
about that I don't know
get some [ __ ] me undies yeah alright
me undies whether your werewolf there
almost went off the rails whether you're
wearing a suit or sweater you spend
almost 24 hours a day and your underwear
but instead of making a statement like
Superman spikes under is everyday
clothes your underwear is probably
boring me undies is here to change that
every pair of my undies is made from
sustainably sourced modal metal Moodle a
fabric that is twice as soft as pot
nothing can describe the fit and feel of
me undies but once you try them on
you'll understand why they're called the
most comfortable goddamn [ __ ]
underwear in the world and that is a
quote and if you don't love your first
pair of me undies they're free no
questions asked me undies has dozens of
styles and limited edition prints to
help make you make a statement huh
you're like that yeah oh yeah you like
that dick curtain and make with your
underwear well whether anyone can see
them or not remember Superman all right
this is the offer call to action here
shipping is free in the US and Canada
and you can save up to eight dollars a
pair with me any subscription plan plan
get the subscription or a single pair
get $20 off your first order when you go
to Munich calm / / that's me on D calm /
/ for 20% off your first order of my
undies calm / / the undies me undies
give them to your brother Tom but you do
to me undies me undies buy a pair for
your mom you like both of them because
you're related now that [ __ ] crotches
are ventilated there we go that was a
better one sorry I had to make up for
that alright Dollar Shave Club
stamps.com that's what I have left but
let me go to the only go your questions
for the week ladies and gentlemen the
questions of the week okay here we go
bike race accident dear bill did you see
the video going around this weekend of
the Brooklyn bike race pileup no I
didn't it really makes you question the
hive mentality of those bikers
I've been involved in some high-speed
activities and their inability to stop
or slow down properly properly is
mind-blowing give it a Google come down
to San Diego once in a while no I
haven't seen that but I do know that
people on a regular basis [ __ ] die
not a regular basis but she definitely
diamonds yeah how fast those [ __ ]
guys go yeah you're riding a motorcycle
without an engine and no he got those
[ __ ] little short dogs get that road
rash it's the exact same thing at - the
muscle burn but I actually I'm a big fan
of bike racing though I always used to
watch the Tour de France and I love
watching Lance win [ __ ] seven in a
row which he did he won seven in a row
okay everybody from him all the way to
the back of the waist
tested positive so I'll never I'll never
give up those seven I'll always say that
he won those [ __ ] things and I gotta
tell you something right now I haven't
watched it since then because it's been
boring without him you know it's like
Tiger Woods ever since his wife [ __ ]
flipped out on him you know and took
half his money the [ __ ] guy hasn't
won [ __ ] and I never watch golf
I do like Phil Mickelson though I like
watching that guy that guy's like the
guy [ __ ] goes for these and give a
[ __ ] he's like yeah you're buying a tree
I'm gonna [ __ ] how much twice right
around this thing I'm going for the pin
I don't know maybe you should lay up hey
look at all the sweat I got into my man
tips you think I'm laying up I'm already
ready for a [ __ ] Arnold Palmer I'm
going for the pin so he does every time
all right drum workout Acer billion big
fan of the podcast and thought I'd share
this with you because I know how much
you love drums and talking about working
out oh yeah recently I I don't know how
I I I missed out on Pantera I just you
know I could never get into that [ __ ]
type of singing you know what I mean
it's like Jesus Christ I heard this in
my house growing up I don't music used
to take me away from this [ __ ] but just
undeniably Vinnie Paul is one of the
great rock drummers of all time without
a [ __ ] doubt and I don't think he
gets the credit
start on my drum teacher bought this
when he's a lot like Alex Van Halen
who's another one of the great drummers
of all time but both of them like Alex
never got to
whoo I feel because Eddie Eddie was just
so [ __ ] insane that everybody focused
on him and they didn't really even
notice how great Alex was and I feel
like Pantera is the same thing it's kind
of creepy how like they both have
brothers like you know they were
innovated innovative you know dime bag
teacher cabbages
there was nobody like either one of
those guitar players in fact and then
you know else was [ __ ] to bring this
full circle is unfortunately when
Dimebag was murdered I always heard that
Eddie donated one of his he loved Eddie
Van Halen and Eddie donated one of his
guitars I think it was that black and
yellow one and they actually bury it
with dime bag so it's kind of a morbid
way to go around if there's Benny Paul's
a [ __ ] amazing drummer but I started
listening that song I'm broken and you
know it's [ __ ] killing me that I
can't just sit down and try to figure
that [ __ ] song out because I don't
got to sit in this [ __ ] writers room
I'm really whining about the writers
room you know because I'm used to just
[ __ ] having my days to myself to just
sit around you know staring at my dry me
on these balls
all right drum workout so this new
workout saw this new workout where you
pretend to play the drums which is
currently available in the LA area see
the video link wanted to hear your
thoughts comment on these modern gym
classes these days
time to start soundproofing that garage
gym thanks for that for the last and go
[ __ ] yourself well why would I don't
understand like Guitar Hero or even I
haven't looked at this [ __ ] workout
class like why wouldn't you just learn
how to play drum well they're not
pretending to play drums they have six
Oh God it's going to be white people
trying to be tribal oh you had sort of
aerobics and then just playing beats
with dicks and stuff oh my god this oh
this is giving me douche Oh
ah there'd like God they always have to
be the person wearing the hat inside the
knitted hat just when you thought that
awful look went away you know the guy
with the [ __ ] skinny jeans the
t-shirt and then like I'm going to have
a snowball fight hat on pretending to
play the drums is now a hot new workout
well they weren't really pretending they
were actually hitting the floor with
them and stuff in hit mystics so he said
there was already a dance from perform
in India called Dania Dania which has
the same concept of dancing with sticks
in a thousand plus years old tradition
oh what a surprise
what a surprise but somebody already
come up with that look if that gets
people in shape it actually kind of
looks like fun but I ears couldn't
handle I'd have to have [ __ ] ear
plugs in I don't know but everyone was
making this Guitar Hero rocket rocking
out phases but what would be cool is if
it actually you know if you take it one
of those classes and you actually want
to learn how to play drums but you know
you can't really play because you have
an apartment I cannot recommend those
rolling v-drums enough they're [ __ ]
amazing and I told you when I had two
two of those kids when I was in New York
it's kind of weird because it's like a
computer like it gets old and then the
new ones better than you like kids you
know if it was gonna cou stick like a
regular drum kick you'd just keep it
drums or [ __ ] drums but they get the
new brains and that better and you just
keep just keep I don't a lot of [ __ ]
money but they're [ __ ] awesome so if
you live if you live like the way I did
way out a neighborhood needs me I went
downstairs and I knocked on the guys
doing it's a blister
I practice drums when do you work I'll
only practice during those hours if
you're ever home when I'm practicing
here's my phone number call me the
second I pick up you tell me to stop I
will immediately stop and we we actually
still at a problem because the first
time he heard me playing here I said
hello he goes can you knock it off and I
just [ __ ] snapped on the guy I was
like through the [ __ ] stay that like
you asked me twelve
time to bid all that [ __ ] and then he
never called me again [ __ ] although
you know in defense to him I can't
imagine what that sounded like
underneath you know not cheese I'm just
[ __ ] dumb just just protracting every
[ __ ] statement alright shoot matches
dear Billy bangers and mash you were
talking about shoot masters shoot
matches on this Thursday's podcast for
those of you who didn't listen a shoot
match is a wrestling term where
basically you know the sports
entertainment you know it's a fake fight
even though they really hurtin each
other but you know it's worked out it's
sports entertainment so technically it's
fake even though they're really throwing
each other and getting hurt it is fake
what happens in a shooting match is
somebody [ __ ] snaps and becomes a
real fight and starts beating the [ __ ]
out of the person for real so he said if
you're into those shoot matches you
should definitely look up a wrestler
named New Jack the psycho was known for
frequently shooting on other wrestlers
for the most minor things in one case he
thought a tag team was trying to steal
his gangster image so he hit them with
chairs full force stabbed him in the
head with forks etc and another match he
basically tries to murder a 67 year old
man those matches are brutal as [ __ ] man
you should check them out I actually saw
those yeah that guy has like
psychological damages damages
psychological damage I knew a guy like
that when I was growing up he went to
[ __ ] cop school surprise surprise you
know [ __ ] it mania actually liked to be
violent like they always end up somehow
being bouncers and cops I'm not saying
they're all like that I'm just saying
it's like you know people that want to
[ __ ] kid you know they're all about
volunteering to take them out into the
wood not saying every cup Scoutmaster as
well I'm just saying you know people who
want to beat the [ __ ] out of people and
don't want to go to jail get jobs where
they have the authority to beat the [ __ ]
out of somebody so this [ __ ] lunatic
so he comes back from like his weekend
get caught
school and I don't know what he did I
never got accepted they just would like
tryout thing I don't know why Kenny was
so [ __ ] long ago so he wants to show
me this move that he learned and he was
doing it in slow motion and then I
remember he just [ __ ] looked up at
the ceiling you know remember how like
the dudes Full Metal Jacket when he's
like I am in a world of [ __ ]
trying to be a GOP you know let that
thing right he keep [ __ ] looked up
like that and just [ __ ] full force did
the move and I heard my [ __ ] wrist
snap and I forget how many times I
punched him in the side of the head I
was so [ __ ] mad at him and I was
really just mad at myself because I knew
that he was one of those guys like he
just [ __ ] like like he was one of
those he was one of the exact type of
personality that you do not teach that
type of [ __ ] too because just it was a
dope he never felt like he had power in
life and then he had this new move and
he just couldn't handle it it was like
you know the whole thing when they would
suck like a baby
poisonous snake is the worst is worse
than getting bit by an adult baby snake
because the adult babies make sort of
rations out the poison where the baby
just gives you [ __ ] both barrels
that's what the [ __ ] he did he had the
mentality of a [ __ ] baby reptiles
what I'm saying and [ __ ] jacked up my
goddamn wrist and hey and you know what
it became a [ __ ] shooting match as
fully as opposed to just show it to me
and I just [ __ ] drilled him in the
side of the head like [ __ ] six times
as hard as I [ __ ] could I was so
[ __ ] mad at him and I remember we
were both drunk and [ __ ] idiot god
bless him anyways moving ahead here that
was a throwback Thursday story all right
fight dear Billy Boy band Billy Boy band
all right everyone been asked everyone's
always asking for advice so here's a
rhetorical who wins in a fight to the
death between a silverback gorilla and a
grizzly bear
one's got IQ and matte upper body the
other has razor-sharp claws and Skull
Crushing jaws thanks and go sit on it
repeatedly know what that means was I
like a happy days rest reference I would
say it depends on if it's a high I'm
rootin I I would go with the home team
all right if it's a home game for the
grizzly bear and they're out an open
field and there's no [ __ ] tree for
the gorillas to [ __ ] go up and then
come back down go up you know do that
[ __ ] monkey [ __ ] where they slap you
in the [ __ ] head I would I would say
the grizzly wins because you know the
gorillas can ball up its fists but you
know you're fighting it's like you're
fighting Freddy Krueger and he's got two
gloves for gloves actually I would say I
don't know and I got a mint like I think
I think gorillas a chill like I don't
think they really like doing that stuff
and I've watched him fight other [ __ ]
gorillas and you know a lot of clutching
and grabbing and [ __ ] and I've watched
two gorillas grizzly bears go at it and
it's [ __ ] devastatingly like how is
one of them not dead so I would say a
grizzly bear I don't know and I'm sure
over in Asia that they have those fights
on the weekend somewhere in Asia they're
doing that right now
because when I go on you two I'm just
basing that on you know we go on YouTube
there's actually black and white footage
of like lions fighting Tigers and [ __ ]
like that and [ __ ] cobras fighting
these things and you know not an
alligator's first [ __ ] cobras or
whatever the [ __ ] they was just you know
like over in Asia like the original MMA
you know UFC type of [ __ ] was actually
animals first animals you know I mean
you got to give it up to I mean I know
that we asked those questions
here over in Asia they actually get it
done you know which makes means that
they're actually killing it more in the
realm of uh don't tell me show me
they're taking the initiative is all I'm
saying
now right here we go get a couple more
here all right let me read the last two
[ __ ] advertisings really quick
advertising advertisements Jesus Christ
it's amazing amazing sometimes that
English is my first language by the way
I'm 64 days in with my French I'm
learning past ten stuff I can look at it
and I can translate it but I can't
recall it because I have no one to speak
it with but I have to think that it's
helping me on some level I think I'll be
able to read a newspaper by the time I
get to [ __ ] France the next time I
just won't be able to talk to anybody
whatever I'll figure something out
alright Dollar Shave Club you guys I
figured it out I've discovered the key
to an amazing shave it's simple
is this me talking right now okay I'm
sorry
hey you guys I figured it out it's
simple that's exactly what
dollarshaveclub.com does and why I'm a
proud member like millions of others I'm
not a member not because I don't like
them I just I can't deal with [ __ ]
trying to sign up for [ __ ] because even
if I sign up for eventually I'm going to
lose my [ __ ] password and it's just a
[ __ ] nightmare dollarshaveclub.com
delivers amazing razors right to my door
for a third of the price of what you get
from those greedy Ranger Corporation
which is true both your wallet and face
finally get some relief joining
dollarshaveclub.com means you can afford
to shave with the fresh blade anytime
you want which feels [ __ ] amazing and
for the smoothest shave ever use your
fresh Dollar Shave Club built blade with
dr. cabbies easy dr. kaar vcug shaper
it's not your average shave cream it's
high-quality ingredients that make your
skin feel soft and smooth and moisturize
your blade will just glide gently across
your skin if you want the most amazing
shape possible take it from me you
fresh Dollar Shave Club blade and dr.
Carvey shave butter two reasons to join
didn't used to say easy shea butter dr.
kobrine ZG shave butter now it's dr.
Carver's shave butter anyways - two
reasons to join a dollarshaveclub.com
slash birt'day that felish
dollarshaveclub.com slash bar alright
sorry the [ __ ] dyslexia is really
chicken anticipation one of my eyes is
on the word I'm reading and the other
one is like three words down I don't
know what that is what is the medical
term for that lazy eye - alright
stamps.com oh the old favourites is
Americans celebrate as America
celebrates National Small Business Week
this week's dance calm wants to honor
not only its over 600,000 small business
customers stamps.com also wants to
extend an invitation to small businesses
throughout the nation to help their
businesses succeed by reducing or
eliminating wasteful trips to the post
office staff comm knows that one of the
most available most valuable resources
as a small business is time you can't
wait fit making constant trips to the
post office for your mailing and
shipping that's why Stan's comm brings
all the services of the post office
right to your desk you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter and
any package any class of mail by using
your computer or printer over six
hundred thousand small businesses are
already using stamps calm you should try
it too I use Stan's calm to spend on any
my posters anytime I'm whoring myself up
after my shows alum [ __ ] if I can
figure out how can how to do it so can
you right now sign up for Stan's calm
and use my last name Barbie you are are
for this special offer for week trial
plus 110 dollar bonus offer including
postage in a digital scale don't wait go
to Stan's calm before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in / @
stamps.com
enter ber all right here we go
and what do I got here I've got the
questions the last two here all right
Tom Brady and Jim Irsay all right even
I'm sick of this [ __ ] story at this
point
what up Billy boy big fan of you bye
blah blah blah blah blah of course
the past didn't beat the Colts by 34
because of a deflated Bowl deflated
balls that's not the point though here's
an example if a baseball player is on
steroid but goes over five on a
particular day what do you mean that's
not the point though I don't know what
point you made I guess you're saying the
deflated ball didn't affect the outcome
the baseball player is on steroid but
goes over five on a particular day does
that mean he didn't cheat of course not
I hate people to do this who asked
questions for me the point I'm making is
that it's not about the results it's
about breaking the rules
so you think is why I can't stand people
that's not this is not what that
decision was about tom brady's was was
his suspension was reinstated not
because it was proven that he cheated
this last trial was all about does a
corporation have a right to discipline
its employee that's what it was about
that's what the NFL was fighting because
Tom Brady opened up a can of worms which
was basically like where your boss and
we said you're suspended he appealed it
outside of the NFL into a court of law
which of course it didn't [ __ ] hold
up because it was a complete kangaroo
court horseshit [ __ ] thing that
happened you know we the owner of the
other [ __ ] team hires the guy to find
dirt on the other [ __ ] team which you
can do on anybody right and then then
one guy plays judge jury and executioner
you take it into a court of law I knew
that thing would get laughed out of
court which it [ __ ] did and Jim Irsay
would look to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] so then
what happened sir is they changed their
argument they then went back to say
listen we are the NFL the corporation
known as the National Football League
Tom Brady is an employee all right we
said that he suspended
we are his boss do we but we argue that
we have the right to suspend our own
employees that's what it was about
okay so this is what kills me about all
these people including Michael Rhett
Michael Rapaport who texted me right he
[ __ ] texted me and he goes haha
[ __ ]
guilty until proven innocent like like
Tom Brady was reached like this
suspension was reactivated thus
vindicating everybody that Tom Brady's
would sheet you guys are not paying
attention to the [ __ ] story that's
not what happened what happened was the
NFL in a court of law
won the right to suspend Tom Brady
because Tom Brady is a [ __ ] Oh God is
anything more relentless than when you
[ __ ] wife call Jesus Christ I got two
more minutes here
alright I'll answer it here hang on a
second I'll answer it hello hello it's
connecting hey I'm finishing my podcast
that's why I have a microphone and
headphones on that's what I call you
right back you but anyways that's what
happens so I'll read the rest of this
guy [ __ ] most Buffalo labelling dopes
think what happened was the the NFL
appealed it and it got proven that Tom
Brady is in fact a cheater that that was
never proven it was never proven alright
so I don't know what so he goes if Brady
broke the rule then he should be
punished I don't know if he did or he
didn't I'm just tired of the argument
that fence passed the Pats blew out the
Colts that doesn't matter
another thing you always say that the
Colts owner got rules changed the
benefited teams what rules were changed
as far as I know he only asked that the
league and force rules that were already
in place know he sat on the Rules
Committee when we beat him when we
roughed up his receivers he bitched
through the referees and the referee
said back to legal he then made a tape
he and and Peyton Manning made a tape
went to the NFL knee and I felt that
that's legal Jim Irsay got on the Rules
Committee he spearheaded a movement to
make the way we covered their receivers
not legal okay the Colts had a better
offense than we did at the time we had a
better defense he made a rule change
that tipped it in favor
of him this guy is [ __ ] filthy he's
[ __ ] filthy those laws were changed
and why do I have to tell you that why
don't you [ __ ] look it up like you
can't find it anyways because as far as
I know he only asked for they know yeah
as far as you know yes because you
didn't look it up the five-yard rule for
receivers has been around forever no it
hasn't
no one hasn't that happened in my
lifetime the first thing was it was the
Mel Blount rule when he beat the [ __ ]
out of golden Richards in the Super Bowl
don't [ __ ] you're speaking in
generalities I can't [ __ ] I can't
stand people like this oh let's get
around forever
oh this glove applause oh this is the
they don't even look it up
that's like burs II went Birds he
[ __ ] goes like you know Joe Montana
had Jerry Rice it's like he didn't have
him for his first two Super Bowls he had
nobody in 81 he had Freddy Stallman and
Dwight Clark those were his number one
and two receivers and he had some guy
Earl Cooper as the [ __ ] running back
he won with nobody he won with people he
won but stars among people who only
stars right [ __ ] Millennials I don't
understand where every pre Millennials
they just don't look at them he said
earth the earth they simply wanted it
enforced what's wrong with that please
respond on your podcast even if you [ __ ]
on me I'll remain a listener you're a
funny [ __ ] dude that's not what
[ __ ] happened and all of this [ __ ]
happen in your lifetime you're just
having selective memory he [ __ ] he
said to the referees look at this tape
look what they did they go yeah we saw
it that's legal unreal unreal and then
they made the tape how do you forget
this [ __ ] it was like a little over 10
years ago go look it up that's what the
[ __ ] happened and then it became then it
became you can't touch him at all it
wasn't after five yards it wasn't before
the five-yard Zero touching was after
them the physical contact that they were
having after that that they were
bitching about and then that's when it
came okay you can do the five-yard Chuck
and then after that [ __ ] you can't
touch anybody at all you
to be able to hand check I'm not saying
like you know that you know ten years
ago you could [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out
of me I'm not saying that but it's
gradually kept moving towards what Jim
Irsay finally had was like okay you can
push the guy you know in the first five
yards and then this is the Jimmer and
the Jim Irsay rule then after that you
can't do anything okay which is why
right after that all of a sudden all of
Dan Marino's records started falling
right and left I remember one year there
was like drew Blees Drew Brees Peyton
Manning and like [ __ ] Tom Brady we're
all on pace to break his like almost
30-year old record of yards in a season
because of those those ridiculous things
it became almost illegal to cover a
receiver it was never like that when I
was growing up ever and if you don't
believe me do your homework go look at
go look at old NFL footage the [ __ ] that
you could do the NBA the same [ __ ]
way you could beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody if they came down the [ __ ]
lane I mean what Kevin McHale did the
Kurt Rambis I mean back in the day that
would be like a 10 game suspension or
whatever you'd be suspended for a number
of games and as far as I know nobody
even got thrown out but I am going back
like thirty years so please just I don't
give a [ __ ] if you want to [ __ ] on my
team but just do your homework that last
trial was about the corporation's right
to suspend an employee that's what was
about it wasn't about whether Tom Brady
was guilty and and for all you [ __ ] out
there who were just obsessed with this
air-pressure
what if Tom Brady had [ __ ] steroids
delivered to his [ __ ] mailbox in his
wife's name give me a [ __ ] break
already
and even then I gotta be honest with you
I don't think steroids changed the
outcome of the game
they helped your personal performance
but if steroids just meant you won the
game then you know teams that did
steroids every day when they just go
undefeated I know it gives you a
competitive edge it does and you know
whatever I I am NOT against steroids I
think steroids should be [ __ ]
legalized they should be researched to
the hilt and just literally for the qual
to your life
that everyone's going to have like any
singers blow out their voices they get
to take a steroid and they go out to
sing the [ __ ] song they'll be in the
crowd says that they cheated right I
don't know
anyways let's plow ahead whatever I'm
[ __ ] I'm done arguing that especially
at this point when all of that
information that I just said is out
there I might add a couple of things
wrong because I don't have literally the
documents and finally but basically what
I'm saying is true and I just don't
argue this [ __ ] anymore okay no matter
what this guy's going to get suspended
because at the end of the day he works
for this [ __ ] corporation and you
know what the NFL is actually right I
think they're wrong to suspend Tom Brady
I think that the investigation and all
that was an absolute [ __ ] witch-hunt
I think all of that is [ __ ] but I do
think that the NFL is the corporation
has to maintain the right to suspend
somebody so if the bus has to roll over
Tom Brady then so be it because it's
going to make for a better league
because if he gets away with this then
everybody's going to appeal it outside
of the NFL and then they lose control
and as much as I'm not a fan of
monopolies as a sports fan it works out
great
like the UFC is to [ __ ] because the
fighters have no options I feel bad for
those guys but it's great for me as the
fight fan because the best guys have to
fight the best guys
alright advice I smell all right I have
a crippling health issue since I was a
kid I [ __ ] stink
people tell me I smell moldy no doctor
knows why cologne and deodorants can't
mask it oh my god he goes the odor
actually gets stronger when I use those
things showering doesn't help so I am
left alone with the this issue I'm
trying to eat as healthy as possible and
exercise every day which seems to reduce
the problem by 50% which sounds like a
lot but still doesn't satisfy me I think
it's a metabolic issue which I don't
know what that is and the body is trying
to get rid of the toxins through the
skin not sure though either way my whole
life revolves around this [ __ ] and it
led me through episodes of depressions
as a teenager and I even considered
throwing myself off a bridge or in front
of one of
those great white trains as Germans are
making but life is actually decent
despite this issue
I can't attend any college classes
because of the anxiety but I have a
great amount of friends I'm happy funny
alright looking guy and my game is
alright so I still get my dick wet
sometimes gross I can't lock down any
girl though for obvious reasons I don't
even know why I wrote all of this but I
just wanted to tell you that this
podcast and your comedy are really
stimulating my budget thinking brain
please come to Germany so we can see
your show and I can harass your nose
thanks for reading and go [ __ ] yourself
and your dog just kidding I like your
dog just go [ __ ] yourself alright dude I
would just keep going to doctors bill
today I bet they could figure something
out
you know there's got to be some new agey
type of thing some sort of detox if it's
your body getting rid of a toxin maybe
you're allergic to something I have no
idea I am NOT obviously not a doctor
here but yeah detox fasting changing
your diet there's got to be there's got
to be a way to do that I remember a long
time ago there was some woman that just
had was talking about she had brutal
halitosis which is uh you know your
breath [ __ ] stinks it was [ __ ]
brutal and it turned out she had some
sort of sinus infection and then once
they cleared that out for [ __ ] her
breath was fine so I bet you have this I
you know if I had to guess there's
something undiagnosed and you know how
god I'm so in over my head
you got something maybe you have some
sort of [ __ ] infection I have no
[ __ ] idea and I bet you know there's
got to be something it is difficult and
app and drive the [ __ ] work and not
kill anybody they got to figure out why
you're mouldy I would just keep going to
specialist tonight if you guys have
nationwide health care over there I
would just that would be my new hobby
you know and just keep adding to your
file and somebody comes in and somebody
will finally crack the [ __ ] case as
to why you smell moldy I bet they
figure it out you know and that would be
great as you went through the alienation
of this that you got the sense of humor
that comes from feeling alienated and
your life will be a [ __ ] joke after
that I mean think about it - if you
could just stop smelling moldy I would
think that that's the number one thing
and then you'd be happy you know your
life would be a [ __ ] joke so if you
have nationwide health care I would be
seeing a doctor like [ __ ] every
couple of days all right buddy
it's like you're pulling people out of
the crowd it hit the half-court shot
eventually it's the balls going to go in
I believe in - it's [ __ ] Germany you
guys got you guys did a [ __ ] you know
half our space program we stole from you
guys the whole seeds of it audio tape
all that [ __ ] you guys had better
machine guns that we did ours would
overheat so if we killed you we actually
picked we dropped our guns and picked up
your machine guns there's no [ __ ] way
2016 they can't figure out why you're
mouldy I feel bad for you man I'm
rooting for you and I hope you figure it
out before you come out to my show and I
should probably know the answer if they
didn't you know all right
go [ __ ] yourselves I have a great week
and I'll check in on you on Thursday see
you